I just looked at the format that the
long-distance races the way the strategy
comes into play you gotta be quite
course you've got to treat the car well
again today into the race we can't push
every single otherwise the tires the
brakes give up
the long races and the hard fighting all
through the race that's the most fun
part
I think patience is a big big thing in
this type of racing we all know you can
never win a race from the first corner
I've always been a fan of endurance
sports car racing
and we have a rolling start so you don't
cover these done that grid tension layer
much legs shaking as you're waiting for
the lights change degree turn in Cheney
Basin and darkness when you're hired
concentrators backtrack and if that
message in cement cooks right
which the cast everyone loves these type
of cars or the cars that you aspire to
own on the road so to be able to race
them is fantastic
they never feel we go fast enough until
you're into the wall they probably got
too fast
you've got to be very consistent over
the long distances the combination
exactly so many elements so when you put
it together
and you know you have the perfect
package the first time landed up upside
down so I didn't really know where I was
and then the second time I I hit the arm
coach and talked about 16g so I was
knocked out and taking this sword that
one but the good thing is crushes
normally happen so fast I don't know we
have too much time to think about it and
then we're normally quite simply as
drivers so we get back in the car next
week and carry on